an inexperienced quarterback now though
try to throw forward in third and six
Buckner back pedals and delivers a throw
and the catch is made by mayor he's
still running across the football has to
fall on it took a very lucky bounce for
the big fella they end up having a
corner cam Brown is on him who's very
capable in coverage but I don't know if
he can handle the physicality a little
push off at the top of the round and
mayor is a big man for a corner to try
to match up with
Tyrone Cellini has returned to the game
for the SC defense off the play fake
Pine launches to the end zone jump ball
punt touchdown Michael Mayer
[Applause]
salty down there a lot watch this when
you get him one on one you've got to be
able to take advantage of that Max
Williams who's had a great year just
over match just nothing he can he's five
nine and God bless him he's a great
player he's a scrappy player but you're
going up against the tight end at 6-5
260 and I love the position the
placement of the ball by Pine to bring
it back Lindsay the only receiver
behind on the Move fires into heavy
traffic they had Mayors surrounded Pine
found him makes the catch inside the 40.
you go with two tight ends you're gonna
get a nine-man front just a fork gets
off the fake but look at this throw look
where he puts this in I mean again I
know you love the big guys six five two
sixty but I really thought four Williams
with receivers really gave him a chance
and fires into the end zone and that's
mayor again building on what is a
tremendous night for him again eight
catches now and a couple touchdowns for
the big tight end
he's been seeing them split which means
you've got the opening in the middle and
who better to split those safeties than
mayor at 6'5 throw right over the
backers safeties have no chance of
converging on that